what's up I'm Stephen Curry and I am
here to play with some puppies and
answer questions let's get it
I have two dogs of my own and grew up
with a bunch of dogs had Labradors we
have Doodles now in our house I'm a dog
lover come on bring them home or maybe
how many Pebbles you got is it a
surprise they're all
done oh that's dangerous
that is dangerous
[Music]
we got toys look you match my pants
don't get on his head
a lively bunch okay uh we ain't doing
that we ain't doing that
probably after my second year in the NBA
I was back home in Charlotte and I was
at a car wash getting my car detailed
and while I was waiting on my car to
come through a fan came up and
recognized me and asked me if I could
sign something for his kid so of course
I said yes but he didn't have any paper
or anything really for me to sign so he
went into his car looked in his glove
box and he found his kids birth
certificate in there I don't know if
that was the facing government property
or whatever the case is but I might have
broken the law there but uh yeah I
signed a birth certificate in Sharpie
for somebody soon
foreign
[Music]
people don't realize I'm six three which
is kind of above average height but when
you see me out there with all the six
eight six nine seven Footers I look
small but they see me in person they're
kind of surprised that I'm taller than I
live on the court
mom is an educator so I've probably been
like a school teacher teacher slash
coach doesn't have like a keychain
walking around the school with like this
[Music]
special time in my life in terms of my
formative years where I learned a lot
about myself as a basketball player as
an athlete I was surrounded by some
amazing teammates and coaches where I
really adopted the underrated mindset of
being able to take you know an
opportunity that wasn't what I
envisioned you know coming up thinking I
was going to play you know High major D1
basketball but you know getting
overlooked in the recruiting process and
finding a place that was perfect for me
in the sense of somewhere where I could
really kind of Blossom at my own pace
didn't have to really compare myself to
anybody it could really come into my own
and understand who I was I went off to
court now that's a story that's not just
for sports that's that's the story for
life and sports is a microcosm of life
and I think looking back to
where I started and where I am now um I
think it was a hopefully an inspiring
story to tell
pastor present I would pick Shaquille
O'Neal as my Center
Tim Duncan is my power forward Larry
Bird is my small forward am I on the
team
Michael Jordan is my shooting guard late
edition I'm not taking Larry I'm taking
Kobe as my small forward Jordan at my
shooting guard and Magic Johnson at
point guard I won't be on the team
[Music]
try to find my happy place in terms of
my thoughts I breathe take deep breaths
Embrace whatever is happening in that
moment you know whatever the challenge
might be or however my emotions are but
I think my work ethic is the thing that
helps give me the most confidence in
those you know environments and those
moments because it means that I'm
prepared for whatever the task is and I
don't really worry too much about the
results I just more worry about the
process and for me that's that's a
comfort zone
kind of starts with one trying to get
good sleep obviously I work out for a
living so I don't really have to worry
about exercise too much in my spare time
and spend a lot of time with my family
my wife my kids find families to get
outside usually playing golf so I can
enjoy nature
I use sweet July skin on my face I think
other than that it's just trying to find
good balance in terms of being with the
people I love and also finding things
that kind of scratch the competitive
itch outside of basketball
[Music]
there's a Killer Instinct inside that it
comes out on the basketball court for
sure but first and foremost I just try
to have fun I try not to take anything
too seriously in that respect
probably Draymond you immediately
respond to my face time be tight like
that
[Music]
a little frisky aren't you best advice I
would have gotten was to fall in love
with the process don't ever be results
driven because that's where you can kind
of start chasing shadows and lose sight
of the experience and the journey like
the process and your discipline on a
daily basis and how you can just get
like one percent better every day that's
the magic sauce the results will come
but you can't force it
get it all moving but my kids
best North Carolina Cuisine has to be
North Carolina Barbecue
[Music]
he is a human encyclopedia he literally
has the most out of left field facts
that he'll drop on you at any moment
he's got the most interesting mind I
think I've ever been around
[Music]
lamb chops and pan seared scallops brown
sugar chicken and pesto chicken but if I
had to pick one favorite it's her
chicken Parmesan
which was one of the first things she
she made for me
do I cook no I do not I have one recipe
it's a five ingredient pasta so you
can't really mess it up got egg noodles
Italian sausage basil bell pepper and
parmesan cheese takes about 15 minutes
to make and if anybody is asking me to
cook dinner that's what you get
[Music]
Aisha Curry can cook for night night or
it's a baby face assassin or that's
about it that's three
[Music]
highly highly highly motivated just
because I knew who I was and I didn't
need nobody to tell me I didn't need any
extra people in the tank but it
definitely motivated me to figure out
that NBA level pretty quick so I could
prove it to more myself more than
anybody
I mean a hole-in-one is pretty special
and hard to come by not to rub it in but
I've seen people play golf for years and
years and years and never have one so it
just doesn't touch anything that I've
done on the basketball court so golf has
a special place in my heart but
I know what my day job is
[Music]
good for the league to have a little
excitement early in the season and
hopefully we can win the uh the
championship in season tournament so
that you know there's a little extra
incentive in terms of you know some of
the payouts of the players 500 000
that's a good day at the job but it'll
take an identity of its own over the
course of a couple years but I think
this first year will be fun to watch
you know having been around when my dad
was playing the league and seen the buzz
in Seattle when they were there I think
that's a good City I think Las Vegas
would be a good City knowing some of the
other sports franchises you got the aces
the knights the Raiders maybe Nashville
[Music]
I got him at the tail end of his career
but I'd probably say Leandro Barbosa he
had the most underrated layup Packers I
think in the history of the league
I'd be truly supportive I think what me
and Aisha try to do is expose them to as
many things as possible let them have
amazing experiences as kids to figure
out what they're passionate about if
that happens to be basketball that'd be
great if it's anything else we'll try to
make sure that they have the resources
necessary to succeed at it but it's only
going to be on their own work ethic and
you know what they want to put into it
but we'll be supportive parents through
and through doesn't have to be
basketball
make sure y'all check out Stephen Curry
underrated it is out now on Apple TV
plus all of these beautiful puppies are
available for adoption they need a
caring home so they'll bring a lot of
energy to your house check them out
North Shore Animal League America
foreign
[Music]